[Musica]
[Applauso]
quanti di voi si ricordano un episodio
dove hanno provato stupore
sì è vero richiede qualche minuto per
andarlo a pescare nella memoria nella
mia mente
se ci penso scorgo un ricordo nitido
avevo circa 5 anni e mi trovavo con mio
nonno che lavorava in un piccolo
sgabuzzino il giardino in una giornata
di sole mio nonno era sempre la
falegname ormai in pensione schizzava
disegni su fogli e sarà questo valli
sarà questo valla sapeva creare
modellini di macchine congegni orologi
velieri e altre cose che accendevano la
mia fantasia
sapete che effetto fa far vedere una
bambina come ero io
creare uno di questi congegni ve lo dico
io
ha un effetto dirompente un mese fa ho
festeggiato i nove anni dall uscita del
mio libro automation robotics
automazione e robotica di leonardo da
vinci
questo mi ha portato lontano in terre
luoghi e sensazioni e dato più di quanto
una ipoteca sulla felicità possa mai
fruttare
chi di voi ha letto asimov io durante la
mia adolescenza ne ero innamorata e
sognavo mondo piano di robot avevo
ancora negli occhi mio nonno ancora
troppo piccola vedevo creare ideare
modificare e infine realizzare dei pezzi
unici in legno l'odore del vinavil il
suo sguardo attento io ferroso dietro
gli occhiali e poi tutta una serie di
fogli su cui rotismi ingranaggi leve
molle balestre avevano la meglio su gli
scarabocchi e sui suoi tentativi
e al contempo scrivevano la mia storia
sì perché ancora non sapevo che quella
sarebbe diventata la mia vocazione
grazie a saper sviluppare questa
capacità straordinaria di sapere che
cosa ci ha schizzato sopra un foglio sia
esso stesso realizzato 30 anni fa oppure
500 anni fa
poi io ho incontrato lui il professor
carlo pedretti che era è e sarà per me
per sempre il più famoso studioso di
leonardo da vinci partito da bologna con
una passione irrefrenabile con una
precisione chirurgica per il metodo il
rigore del lavoro e con una capacità
straordinaria e indiscutibile di
ricomporre e studiare le carte di
leonardo arriva da giovane a los angeles
e da lì in tutti i testi a cui uno
studioso si deve avvicinare se vuoi
conoscere e poi successivamente
approfondire lo studio di leonardo
adesso sono sono specializzata nella
nell'automazione nella robotica nei
congegni idraulici e pneumatici
nell'orologeria nei teatri nella
meccanica statica e dinamica di leonardo
fu proprio sua l'idea del professor
pedretti dai sarà scrivilo questo libro
sulla robotica scrivi quello che ti
sembra di vedere
fammi vedere vi faccio vedere da un
punto di vista tecnologico gli automata
dalla parola greca automatiche si muove
di propria volontà possono essere
definiti come l'esito più alto raggiunto
dall'uomo nella gara di mimesi con la
natura
essi sono dei veri e propri miracoli di
ingegneria meccanica che erano stati
proprio creati per destare meraviglia e
stupore per le corti dei signori più
potenti del tempo in questa definizione
automata o se vogliamo secondo
l'antichità classica simulacra auto
cinetici rientrano dei robot degli
automi che quindi riproducevano le
fattezze umane anima
ma anche tutti i congegni più complessi
come per esempio fontane congegni
idraulici pneumatici orologi e teatri
una delle prime e menzioni del termine
automata addirittura la ritroviamo
nell'iliade di omero
nel testo infatti si racconta di
specializzati operai robot che si
muovevano liberamente quindi da soli
nella magica fucina di efesto non a caso
dio del fuoco dei metalli e della
tecnologia
e sapete che l'esito più alto fu appunto
raggiunto dalla scuola alessandrina in
particolar modo con la figura di air one
di alessandria che accanto a congegni
molto più complessi come per esempio
quello di poter spalenza spalancare da
sole le porte di un tempio andava a
ricreare dei robot che si muovevano
sfruttando la pressione dell'aria
sull'acqua sappiamo poi che la
conoscenza dell'antichità classica nel
campo della robotica passa poi al mondo
arabo in particolar modo la somma per la
conoscenza della meccanica araba ci
viene tramandata dalla figura di un
inventore astronomo e artista alza
nasari di cui si hanno notizie tra il
1100 36 e il 1206 ora proprio nel 1206
abbiamo il suo libro sui dispositivi sui
fantasiosi meravigliosi dispositivi
meccanici nel quale sappiamo
dell'esistenza di una cosiddetta fontana
del pavone una sorta di dispenser di
acqua e sapone oppure della favolosa
nave de musici che è capace di librarsi
e muoversi su uno specchio d'acqua
poteva ricreare una sorta di vero e
proprio me la dia
grazie a questi robot musi muniti di
strumento per allietare magari i
sontuosi banchetti del tempo bene
facciamo un salto nel tempo e arriviamo
a milano
1482 leonardo arriva alla corte di
ludovico il moro anche l'ambiente
milanese era un ambiente ricco di
stimoli e di eccellenza tecnologica
giovanni fontana una sorta di inventore
fantasiose una figura poliedrica fu il
padre di questa della cosiddetta strega
infuriata una sorta di creatura ibrida
meccani
se mi movente dotata di coda di serpente
e ali di pipistrello che sbucando fuori
all'improvviso perché mossa su alcune
rotaie poteva destare sicuramente paura
ma anche meraviglia e poi era anche il
padre del diavolo meccanico una sorta di
antecedente di questo bellissimo e
meraviglioso diavolo ligneo capace di
muoversi che è conservato alla
collezione settala del museo del
castello sforzesco di milano
anche leonardo nel 1492 si misura con
questo compito cioè quello di disegnare
quello perché per gli studiosi era stato
definito un automa cavaliere questo
progetto viene ad essere schizzato su
vari fogli del codice atlantico che voi
sapete conservato nella veneranda
biblioteca ambrosiana di milano e in
particolar modo il foglio più importante
è questo il 579 recto nella quale
appunto leonardo studia questo complesso
sistema di carrucole di ingranaggi in
particolar modo grazie a questi quattro
dispositivi proprio nel 2010 nel mio
libro avanzavo l'ipotesi di poter
leggere questo cavaliere automatico come
un tamburino quindi vale a dire un
musico dotato di un tamburo melodico che
potesse in qualche modo scandire il
ritmo del fesr delle feste e dei balli
ma anche le entrate ufficiali alla corte
degli sforza questa mia intuizione ha
ricevuto una menzione speciale in un
articolo su scientific american
intitolato ai robot fatto da un
ingegnere della nasa che si è
complimentato e che ha decretato questo
successo della mia intuizione da un
punto di vista tecnico
questi studi di leonardo sulla meccanica
e sulle automatismi sui robot
determinavano l'incontro e forse anche
lo scontro tra gli studi del campo
dell'anatomia e della cinetica e gli
veniva quindi pertanto a tracciare una
sorta di anatomia artificiali in cui il
corpo umano era paragonato ad una
macchina egli stesso a un certo punto va
a definire il corpo umano come una
macchina meravigliosa perfettamente
congegnata
e quindi pertanto si assistono sorta di
vero e proprio parallelismo tra gli
organi come ingranaggi e il corpo come
macchina lo stupefacente leone meccanico
invece fu un allegoria politica fatta
sfilare davanti al nuovo re di francia
francesco primo a lione nel 1515
sappiamo che fu commissionato a leonardo
dai facoltosissimi banchieri fiorentini
di stanza a lione e doveva rappresentare
una sorta di vero e proprio grazioso
dono diplomatico fortemente
politicizzato a questo punto è che
andava a sancire una sorta di
strettissima alleanza tra firenze e la
francia questo leone viene ad essere
studiato soltanto in questo foglio
appartenente al codice di madrid ma
abbiamo delle testimonianze infatti
giovanni paolo lomazzo nel 1584 ci disse
una volta dinanzi al francesco primo re
di francia fece camminare da sua posta
in una sala un leone fatto con mirabile
artificio e poi fermato aprendosi il
petto tutto pieno di figli e diversi
fiori l'unica testimonianza diretta
invece è una testimonianza posteriore
scritta da michelangelo buonarroti il
giovane nipote del ben più famoso
michelangelo contemporaneo di leonardo
che ci descrive le nozze tra maria de
medici appunto di firenze e enrico iv
allora appunto re di francia e dice
nella testa della tavola di mezzo di
quelle gentildonne per colmare la
meraviglia in aspetto fiero leone ebbe
che posando su quattro piedi allora che
a tavola l si misero prendendo moto e
sollevandosi in due aprirsi il seno si
vide e pieno di gigi mostrarlo concetto
simile a quello il quale leonardo da
vinci nella città di lione nella venuta
del re francesco primo mese in opera per
la nazione fiorentina questo giovane
osservatore ci va a sottolineare che già
appunto nel 1600 quindi molto dopo
rispetto a al primo congegno di leonardo
si perpetuava in francia ancora il
ricordo della tecnologia vinciana
attraverso il leone di più piccole
dimensioni
che però si muoveva sopra questo
banchetto nuziale e andava incontro
appunto agli sposi rispetto a tutti gli
automi dell'antichità questo di leonardo
è il primo automa che non sfrutta
soltanto una fase meccanica ma
addirittura a un programma interno che
sporche che sfrutta fasi meccaniche in
diverse fasi di tempo e individuate
cinque dunque il leone meccanico era
capace di muoversi attraverso da un
punto di vista tecnico lo slancio delle
balestre e lo svolgimento delle molle
poteva colmare una distanza molto
ridotta dai 35 metri massimo poi un
meccanismo interno determinava quindi
pertanto che leone si alzasse a sedere
sulle zampe posteriori e si riattiva va
un meccanismo simile alla prima fase in
cui appunto si apriva una sorta di vero
e proprio sportellino dal tetto ed erano
capaci di ricadere al suolo in omaggio
del re dei gigli il giglio naturalmente
aveva un grandissimo valore politico e
simbolico era un allusione alla città
gigliata per eccellenza sua firenze e
quindi pertanto anche al fior del
francese in questi studi leonardo va a
riflettere quindi pertanto come potete
immaginare sul tema del movimento della
trasformazione del mondo naturale e va a
tracciare quello che secondo una
straordinaria definizione si può
descrivere come una sorta di meccanica
dell'universo e quindi pertanto accanto
al volo degli uccelli che lui studia nel
codice del volo conservato alla
biblioteca reale a torino
non potevano mancare gli uccelli
meccanici volanti che potevano librarsi
in aria come un giocattolo nelle mani di
un bambino
io so che ognuno di voi ora mi vuol fare
la domanda della serata ma leonardo è
stato a bergamo
sì abbiamo sappiamo che leonardo
conosceva benissimo le valli lombarde in
particolar modo le studiava per la loro
idrografia e per ragioni strategico
militare ma tutte le volte che l'occhio
del cartografo incontro l'occhio del
naturalismo si hanno questi disegni
meravigliosi che non
sono soltanto una restituzione del
territorio ma descrivono letteralmente
il territorio ogni cartografia ogni
schizzo cartografico è il leonardo
un'opera d'arte e quindi vediamo come in
questo primo disegno anch'esso
conservato come gli altri due che
vedremo alla biblioteca reale a windsor
quindi nelle collezioni della resina
vediamo la val brembana e poi oltre la
linea obliqua la val trompia e la
valsabbia
vediamo che appunto bergamo è
identificato con questi 22 piccoli
cerchi che corrisponderebbero quindi
pertanto come mi insegnate ai due luoghi
insediativi quindi della città basse
della città alta
poi abbiamo uno studio del bacino del
l'olio e in questa carta la cosa curiosa
è che tutti i paesi che si ergono sulle
sponde del fiume sono scritti in
dialetto bergamasco e questo quindi
pertanto è una prova che lui stesso era
in questi luoghi molto spesso voi non lo
vedete ma sono molto piccoli ci sono le
distanze che intercorrono tra villaggio
il villaggio e quindi pertanto hanno una
prova di presenza sul territorio
poi abbiamo anche la valle del serio
dove ritroviamo la città di bergamo
invece qui identificata soltanto con un
cerchio appunto per riandare a
identificare la città che si quindi si e
si ergeva alla fine di questo tragitto
d'osservazione molto importante quello
che io ho appreso durante tutti questi
anni e di cui vi ho dato velocissimo
scorcio una piccola parte è stato
proprio quel sentimento di non perdere
mai questo sentire straordinario che ho
sono riuscita a imparare accanto alla
migliore persona che potevo mai avere la
500 anni a questa parte quindi professor
pedretti e anche dalla possibilità di
non perdere mai la curiosità che mi ha
sempre caratterizzato fin da bambina la
scoperta è questo che ancora mi emoziona
e il desiderio di farla di mettermi
sulla sua scia di acciuffarla è proprio
la molla che muove gli ingranaggi del
mio cuore
grazie
[Applauso]